[Music]
there's a very famous phrase in the
legal community hard cases make bad law
and the circumstances that Apple and the
FBI and the Justice Department find
themselves in certainly not by design
it's a horrible tragedy that led to it
but this is a wonderful example of a
very hard case you have without question
somebody who has done an evil evil
murderous thing and they have used the
device that contains information that
might be not just marginally
extraordinarily useful to law
enforcement all over the world certainly
into the United States in either solving
aspects of this crime or preventing
future atrocities from occurring
no question Apple says that it is not
and this happens to be an Apple device
Apple has designed their devices so that
people can protect their information and
now a federal judge has ordered Apple to
help crack the phone and being access to
that information an apple in a very
interesting letter from its CEO Tim Cook
has said well we don't we are what
rejecting the judge's order to help
crack this why why because the problem
that emerges is do people have any
expectation or reasonable expectation of
privacy when they use technologies on
networks by exceeding to the judges
request and the FBI's request a message
would be sent to people all over the
world China Europe Latin America the US
that if a rule of law if a judge Chinese
judge Brazilian judge Russian judge says
that thing that you've encrypted on your
device we want access to it it would
basically mean you
no privacy if a rule of law and let's be
very blunt here Chinese and Russian rule
of law standards are different than
American or British or German rule of
law standards
nobody could count on their devices to
protect them in any other circumstances
to my mind that is the definition of a
hard case I am extraordinarily
sympathetic to Apple I'm extraordinarily
sympathetic to the FBI and the Justice
Department I am even more sympathetic to
the families of the people who were hurt
and killed in in that in that attack
that terrorist attack but the reality is
this is one of those circumstances where
there is no good answer and whatever
answer is chosen is the wrong one
[Music]